here's another thing my friend Janice
Martorano taught me which is that
there's a way that you can integrate
meditation into your daily life in short
bursts so she calls them purposeful
pauses I'm not a huge fan of that it's a
little jargony sergeants I do love you
but let's go with that phrase
essentially her argument is there are
times during the day that we often use
to let our ego our inner narrator run
wild like when your computer is booting
up in the morning or when you're driving
to work or when you're waiting for the
elevator you can actually co-opt those
in-between moments to just focus on
what's happening or focus on your breath
which is a great way to boost the muscle
of focus it's also a great way to reduce
that frazzled feeling that is kind of
the background static of our lives
bringing yourself to a point of focus
repeatedly through the day can just make
you feel a lot less hectic than you need
to feel that's not to say that you were
gonna stop feeling crazed we all feel
crazed especially if we're doing
something we love in a high-pressure
environment but there's a way to
minimize it the meditation isn't about
erasing all of your problems are
clearing the mind which is a huge huge
PR problem for meditation it's about
creating a different relationship to the
chaos of the mind in 1984 during a
presidential debate Ronald Reagan looked
over at Walter Mondale and uttered the
famous words there you go again for me
at least 10% of the time I'm able to
look at the casts of my mind and say
there you go again I'm standing in line
at Starbucks somebody cuts me off and I
can see that my mind saying you're angry
this is bad you know I can feel my chest
buzzing in my ears getting hot and I can
catch what's going on and not take the
bait that is a superpower that makes you
the common person in the room during a
high-intensity meeting that makes you
less likely to check your email when
your kid is talking to you that's you
makes you less likely to put your hand
in the fridge when you're not actually
hungry this is a huge value add again to
be repetitive deliberately it's not
going to solve all of your problems but
I make a 10 % happy